Over the last couple of months, like
many others, I've used Claude Code a
lot. I've used it to help me build
projects like build my graphics, some
other projects which are yet to launch,
and lots of internal tools. I'm not
using it for wipe coding to be very
clear about that. But I'll get back to
how I use it because that's exactly what
this video is about. I want to share my
top cloud code usage strategy. My six
top usage strategies. The six things I
would recommend doing when you're using
cloud code to get good results. Now,
it's worth noting that I'm using Cloud
Code with the Max plan, which gives you
20x the usage. Obviously, heavily
subsidized by Anthropic, but you get
lots of usage out of cloud code here.
And if you're not running cloud code in
a loop, in a Ralph loop, and there's
been lots of hype about that, then you
get plenty of usage out of it. And
that's actually already my first point.
I don't loop. I don't RLE. I stay in
control. And that's important to me. I
know there's lots of hype these days
about running Claude code in a loop. We
have that entire Ralph Wigum thing here
where the idea is that you have a
detailed product requirement document.
In the end, a document that details all
the different steps you need to take to
build the product you want to build. and
you hand that document off to u clawed
code in a loop, a simple bash loop for
example, where you run cloud code over
and over again with a prompt where you
tell it to look into the document, pick
the next step, tackle that step, and
then work its way through the document
until it's done. And the idea simply is
that by having a detailed plan, you get
good results. Now, I will totally agree
that a detailed plan matters. Planning
matters. I totally agree with that. It
absolutely does matter no matter what
you're building. But I'm not a fan of
the AI working its way through a plan on
its own. Instead, I like to stay in
control. As I mentioned, that is really
important to me. I feel like AI can be a
very helpful tool for developers. And I
shared that in plenty of other videos on
my other YouTube channel, Maxim
Schwartzer. I feel like AI can be a very
helpful tool for developers. I believe
every developer should use AI as a tool,
but I don't feel like it can really give
me good results if I let it run on its
own. That's why I'm absolutely not into
vibe coding. I tried the Ralph loop. I'm
not just saying that without testing it.
For me, the results were not convincing.
I want to stay in control. And kind of
related to that, my second point is use
plan mode because plan mode is amazing.
In cloud code, you can cycle through
different modes with shift tab. And
there is a plan mode built into claude
code. And the idea behind that mode, and
I'm sure you know that, is simply that
it does not go ahead and execute changes
right away or that it does something
based on your prompt right away, but
that instead first it gathers
information. It explores the codebase.
It tries to understand your prompt. It
may also look up documentation,
though I'll get back to that. And then
it makes a plan. And then you uh approve
that plan or not. It may even ask you
some questions if more clarification is
needed. Now, plan mode therefore is
really helpful for a couple of different
reasons. For one, it can save bad
prompts. So, if you're writing poor
prompts, plan mode can help you here
because it can kind of help you get to a
better prompt by asking follow-up
questions. It might clarify things that
might not be clear from your prompt. But
of course, you should try to write good
prompts in the first place because
that's important. AI is a tool. The
output will only be as good as your
input. And even then, there is
randomness involved. Let's be honest.
But if you're throwing bad, unprecise
prompts with missing context at the AI,
you will not get great results out of
it. So good prompts with good context
engineering. So with the right context
being provided matter. So good prompts
are still important. That is really uh
worth noting here. But of course you
definitely have plan mode as a little uh
well savior that can come in. But that's
still just one advantage of plan mode.
Another advantage of plan mode is that
it shows you what the AI wants to do.
And that is really valuable in my
experience because it's far too easy to
just blindly trust the AI to do
something and that it does the right
thing. But hey, it's AI. It's not
necessarily going to do the right thing.
It's definitely not necessarily going to
write the code you might want it to
write. And the great thing about plan
mode is that even if you don't get
follow-up questions, so even if your
prompt maybe already was good enough,
like here for me in this example, I
still get a plan. And I know a lot of
developers that will just blindly accept
that plan. So that we'll just hit uh
enter and let it do its thing. But don't
be that kind of developer. Take a look
at that plan. It tells you what it wants
to do. If you asked it to fix an issue
or find a solution for a bug, it will
tell you what it thinks causes the bug.
And by the way, when I say think, you
always want to keep in mind that you're
dealing with token generators here. But
still, it will tell you what it wants to
do. And you should take a look at that.
And then here's the shocking part. You
should feel free to edit that plan. So
don't blindly accept it. Edit and tweak
the plan if needed. You can and should
do that. It's nothing you have to just
accept and get done with and then fix
any problems that might occur
thereafter. Instead, take a look at the
plan, tweak it to your likings, and then
accept it. Because you can always go to
that fourth point here and say, "I don't
like the text on the 44 page." and then
be more precise. And then you can get it
to generate a new plan, which you then
may accept. And that's a way better
approach than letting it do its thing
just to then find out that you don't
like what it did and you wanted to fix.
That burns more tokens, is more work,
wastes time, and fixing code with AI is
not a lot of fun. And by the way, I
cover in detail how to use cloud code,
how to write prompts, how to do context
engineering, how to provide general
roles, how to use tools cloud code
offers like agents or skills to which
I'll get back in this video too, and
much much more. And I'll build a
complete demo project in a brand new
course I just launched about claude
coding. You find a link to that course
with a great discount below the video in
case you're interested. The third point
here is that I use agents and skills.
And what do I mean by that? Cloud code
allows you to build custom sub aents.
Something I also show in my course like
with all the things I mention here and
much much more. The idea here is that
claude code can launch these sub aents
with their own dedicated context window
to save tokens in the main context
window so that you don't run out of
context space there. And those agents
can then specialize in certain tasks.
And one agent I like to build which I
also build in that course is a docs
explorer agent for example which is
simply an agent optimized for browsing
documentation. And I give that agent
certain tools like web search or the
context 7 MCP. So I give that agent uh
those tools. The context 7 MCP in case
you don't know is a MCP server that
gives AI agents easier access to the
documentation of thirdparty libraries or
languages you might be working with. I'm
not a huge MCP fan. I will say that uh
because I feel like they're token
inefficient. AI is not that good at
using MCPS in my experience and I prefer
built-in tools and I don't need that
many tools anyways. But the context 7
MCP is pretty amazing. And I built my
own docs explorer agent which has the
specific task of using web search and
this agent to browse for documentation.
And in addition to that custom agent, I
also equip cloud code with skills and
that will be skills that are project
dependent or specific. So for example,
if I'm working in a NextJS project, I
might give it some skill that describes
some best practices I wanted to use in
relation to uh Next.js to ensure that it
uses Next.js or writes NextJS code that
is in line with my expectations and my
preferences. And it's worth noting here
that there also are open- source
initiatives like Versel skills here uh
that make it easy to install specific
skills into projects and load openly
shared open-source skills into a project
like the React best practices shared by
Versel. I will also do that in many
projects, but I still like to craft my
own skills with my very own preferences,
patterns, and simply rules that come
from my experience as a developer that I
want the AI to use. Because the idea
behind the skills is that the AI will
read those skill files when needed. They
are lazily discovered. They're not
always loaded in full into the context.
Instead, they're loaded when the AI
decides that it needs to use a skill.
And then that skill can give the AI
extra context, extra instructions, which
should increase the chances of getting
good results. And that's important here.
We're always talking about increasing
our chances because it's still AI. There
is randomness. You can't be sure that it
does stuff the way you want it to do,
but you can try to increase the chances.
That's the entire game of using AI as a
developer in my experience. And that's
therefore my fourth point here. Explicit
over implicit. Now, what do I mean with
that? With that, I simply mean that the
AI may do something the way I want it to
do, but I can't be sure about it. So,
I'm rather explicit. So for example, if
I'm using the better off library in a
project and I want to use authentication
via Google, I write that explicitly. But
I'll also say something like use the
docs explorer agent which is that custom
agent I wrote which is good at exploring
documentation which I mentioned before
to explore the relevant better off docs
before implementing because I've seen it
too often that I will just head off and
do something and then I see that it
didn't do what I wanted it to do and
that it for example has access to
certain agents or certain skills but it
just won't use them even though in
theory it And I don't want that. I'm not
getting anything out of saying, "Hey,
the AI is pretty bad. It didn't do what
I wanted to do if I never told it what
it should do." It's a stupid
tool that can be amazing kind of. And
therefore, don't hope that it does
something or don't wait for it to fail
just so that then you can be convinced
that AI is not good. Instead, know that
it is good at generating lots of code
quickly and use that as its strength and
give it the necessary instructions it
needs to increase the chances of getting
the output you want essentially. So
that's what I mean with explicit over
implicit. I rather tell it explicitly
what I wanted to do. If I know what I
want it to do, then that I hope that it
does that. I hope that makes sense. I
have no problem with telling the AI
something which it maybe would have done
anyways if I can then be sure that it
will do what I wanted to do. So for
example here it used the docs explorer
to look up the better off docs and I
didn't have to hope for that. My fifth
point is kind of related to this. Trust
but verify. AI is great and if you give
it a good prompt, if you're specific, if
you provide the right context, depending
on the problem that was tackled, you
have good chances of getting decent
results. But don't blindly trust that
you are in control. So you should verify
the results. You should not blindly
trust them. Carefully review the code.
Don't just think that it's correct.
Think about it critically. Don't dismiss
it as AI generated. It's certainly bad.
Instead, accept what's good and try to
improve what's bad. And bad can also be
something that maybe is okay, maybe
works, but isn't using a pattern or an
approach you want to use. So do that.
But also give the AI tools of
self-verification. So give it tools for
selfverifying because that can vastly
improve results. Actually I guess that's
my second point. The first one is review
the code as I just mentioned. But with
tools for selfverifying I mean stuff
like unit tests, E2E tests
and also potentially depending on what
you're building browser access wire the
playright MCP for example. The idea here
simply is that the AI can do these
things on its own. You might want to
tell it as I mentioned here in explicit
over implicit, but it can run tests. It
can run linting commands for example. So
um that would be something else in here.
And it can also access the browser with
tools like the playright MCP. Though you
want to be careful here that is
tokenheavy. So that burns a lot of
tokens and you don't want to use that
all the time. Therefore, um at least you
want to know that it can burn a lot of
tokens. But giving the AI tools that
help it to evaluate the results on its
own can vastly improve the quality of
the output. It's still not a guarantee.
For example, the AI may write tests that
simply pass and it might adjust the
tests to the code instead of the other
way around. So you want to be careful
but still this can lead to better
results and it does still not mean that
you should not review the code and of
course also test yourself. You want to
do that you're in control and you have
responsibility for the code. You can't
say hey I wrote it. It's bad. Sorry. You
are in control. And then the last one
you're still allowed to write code.
Shocking, I know. But with AI, with AI
tools, it's not an either or choice.
You're still allowed to write code, and
you should still write code. I'm not
going to ask AI, please
rem. I can do that myself. And if you
review the code, if you understand the
code the AI generated, which you should,
getting back into the codebase shouldn't
be too difficult. And don't get me
wrong, I've fallen into the trap of
handing off too much work to the AI and
of not fully understanding the codebase.
I'm not doing that anymore. I make sure
that I always understand the codebase
and that I'm always able to get back in
there because I'm a developer. I can
read code, I can write code, and I can
still write code even when I'm using AI.
So, if AI can't figure something out, if
you have a trivial change where you just
don't want to burn tokens, I mean, those
tokens cost money, just do it yourself.
And by the way, coding is fun, at least
for me. So, I love getting into the code
and writing code myself from time to
time. And it's never been easier with
great autocomp completion in cursor or
VS Code. And therefore this also is uh a
very important point and the last of my
points here. Now as I mentioned I have a
full course where I dive deeper into
cloud code where I dive deeper into
these points many others where I explain
in detail how to build custom agents and
all that fun stuff. You find a link
below.